the serving body camera footage reveals
how chicago police raided the wrong
apartment
and detained an innocent woman an
investigation by our chicago station
that's wbbm-tv
uncovered the video which we have to
tell you is very hard to watch
police tried to withhold it and city
officials tried to keep you from even
seeing it
angenette young who was getting changed
at the time
sued the city of chicago over the
botched effort to arrest a suspect who
actually lived next door
nearly two years after the incident a
judge forced chicago
police to turn over video of this raid
dave savini
of wbw bbbmtv broke the story and spoke
with ms young
as she watched the body cam footage
i just got home from work
and while i was undressing in my bedroom
and jeanette young a social worker had
just finished her shift at the hospital
when police entered her home
and it happened so fast i didn't have
time to put on clothes
she was surrounded by 12 male officers
and i'm just standing there i mean
terrified
humiliated not even understanding why
in that moment that this is happening to
me
almost immediately young is handcuffed
if i hadn't made one wrong move i felt
like they would have shot me
i truly believe that they would have
shot me a police officer wraps a short
coat around her shoulder
still leaving her front fully exposed
[Music]
eventually one of the officers holds a
blanket in place
you need to tell me what you're looking
for it felt like forever for me
it felt like forever young tells the
raid team at least 43 times they are in
the wrong place
you got the wrong house
she was right they were in the wrong
house wbbm's investigation uncovered
police simply took the word of an
informant
who said a felon with a handgun lived in
the
lives here but apartment okay okay
i don't have the shelf cause it's very
ridiculous
you got me in here cause i'm naked you
kicked my house in
and i can't tell you you got the wrong
place so
where was the target our investigation
revealed
he was awaiting trial on home
confinement
here at a different apartment in
angenette young's complex
how easy would it have been to locate
him easy
real easy because he was wearing a
police tracking device
an electronic monitoring bracelet keenan
salter
is angenette young's attorney if this
had been
a young woman in lincoln park
by herself in her home naked a young
white woman let's just be frank
if the reaction would have been the same
i don't think it would have been they
viewed ms young
as less than human police did eventually
walk young to a room so she could get
worker i've been a dressed worker for 20
years i follow the law
i don't get in trouble for anything i
don't do
illegal stuff i'm not that person you
got the wrong
information at this point the sergeant
tells the officer who got the warrant to
step
outside once outside
the body camera is shut off but the
sergeant returns with this message
we believe none of the officers have
been disciplined
mayor lori lightfoot's administration
tried to block cbs chicago
from airing this body camera footage by
filing an emergency motion in court
a judge ruled against the city but the
mayor said she saw the footage for the
first time tuesday
what i've directed my law department to
do is
with respect to this one if there is a
pending case get that case resolved the
work
is warranted they need to do the work
but they need to do it right
they can't just callously do it and
leave people's lives in ruins because
they got it wrong
in a statement mayor lightfoot says she
has no further comment because of
pending litigation and
ongoing investigations now we talked to
her office last year about the raid and
the body cams
so it's unclear why she's saying she's
just seeing the video now for the first
time
meanwhile young and her attorney are
refiling their lawsuit in state court
next week anthony dave savini wbbm there
for some great reporting thank you dave
43 times she told them they were in the
wrong apartment
i can't get over that stand up from dave
there they had a tracker on the suspect
they could have known exactly where he
was yeah
my heart breaks from miss young though
guys because number one the way she said
it was so callous
if you look at the video you can see one
officer just whacking on a piece of gum
like this is just a normal thing that
happens and the fact that you're so
naked when you're the most vulnerable
that you
that you can ever that anybody can be to
be treated that way
is just heartbreaking to see it's just
it's unfathomable when you look at this
video and you see the way that this
woman was treated
and then to be told don't shout don't
scream how do you not shout when you
were being treated this way
in the report no one has been
disciplined so far yeah any other career
field if you make a mistake of that
magnitude something happens to you
you know as hard as it is for ms young
i'm glad we all got to see that video it
just shows you once again
the importance of videotape and the
changes that need to be made certainly
when it comes
again to i agree with that attorney if
the woman had been white
i doubt that it would have been treated
that way she will live with that trauma
forever
no matter what the city does